UKIP's ruling body it's passed a vote of
no-confidence in its leader
Henry Bolton who has come in for heavy
criticism after it emerged that his
girlfriend Joe Marnie sent racist text
messages about Prince Harry's fiance
Megan Markel but mr. Bolton is refusing
to resign instead he claims he wants to
drain the UKIP's swamp and only the
members can get rid of him well how
about Henry Bolton knew of his new
girlfriend's extremely racist views oh
he's just a terrible judge of character
neither option inspires confidence in
him as a leader but being their fifth
crisis stricken leader in two years this
also doesn't bode well for you Kip Henry
Bolton's position is no longer tenable
and you Kipp is a shambles but bread's
it is still very much an open debate and
that's coming from a row manor but there
is a democratic need for a party
representing the millions who voted for
a hard brexit this is why you Kip or a
similar reincarnation must survive
without a party there is a danger that
those voices turns in less palatable
forms of expression without parties
there is called the conservative exactly
they've taken up I mean from the moment
they said bricks it means breaks it and
you can understand why they said it why
should why I may sell it but no I mean
they said picture mean exit the
Conservative Party of increasing become
the blacks apart yeah and they're either
it is an extreme position or let more
moderate picture but it's a SAP exit
party and that's why that's where most
of these you keep people will go I
suspect I mean less when you keep itself
I mean on this program last year I I
said I thought so ours was the
politician of his generation I think we
think of it even more now because there
was no one else there was this great
danger of political parties anyways that
they attract
let's put it politely strange people and
the more extreme the more strange they
are and and you look at what's happened
to you but you think this is a bunch of
very old people for large was you keep
without it for us the reason thank you
but for the supporters also sure it's
the spirits the Tories and the reason I
think that is it kind of misunderstands
all this
diagnosis what you Kipp was I think new
Kip was a single-issue pressure group
that that that hemorrhage votes from
labor and the Tories and so there are a
whole bunch of left-leaning you new
Clippers who who who voted you Kip
because they wanted brexit and so
without that single issue party I what I
wonder where those voices are gonna go
and I say that as somebody look I'm a
remainer I don't believe in brexit but
at the same time it's the reasons why I
said Nigel for I should get be given a
peerage because I do recognize that he
basically filled a void in this country
and provided a voice for people that
felt voiceless and is a one-man band I
do worry about the fact that there is
nobody to replace him and you kid but I
do think the party needs to act as a
vent for angry people that disagree with
where this country headed but it was
only one part you keep that which think
that was to get us out of the that was
not buffalo and flaws then walked away
and it's arguable he should have stayed
for another two three years now for ours
he's talking about a second referendum
because he believes they'll be
overwhelmingly on his side I don't think
that is the case but but I think you
keep is now irrelevant and and just sad
so Greg's pointing ain't in Ghana Greg
we have another why idea which was well
done just add to Greg's point if you
look at who the Conservatives have got
negotiating breaks it they're all hard
breaks tears so I'm sorry we have that
pros part that that place taken a screw
up the productivity is do you keep the
bracelet part I predict it before now I
think it's gonna happen I think that the
dealer to reason a comes back when it's
gonna be too soft for hard bricks of
tears and too hard for remain is like
you and me and I think because that's
going to happen
Faraj is already talking about second
referendum because he's predicting
that's gonna happen and I think that
when that does happen there will be a
place for a party that basically tries
to go harder than the deal to he's
amazed presenting to the country and if
there isn't that party that exists where
will those voices go and I worry and end
up in more underground dodgy extremists
dollar
I don't think we need to worry about
that I am sure Nigel Farage will create
that party if there's of what he said he
won't well we'll see he said many things
there will be a chunk of the
Conservative Party who will run that
campaign yes which it's not hard enough
we want to be harder than this we were
not if they're subjected to the whip oh
wait you've only seen the events of this
week they are another party that's all
I'm quit if you look at the events of
this week and what was happened to Baris
there's no discipline no conservative
party at the moment over that I think
there were nobodies what is wrong and
nobody will be in control well I think
that you kit will let down by our
averting system in this country because
back in 2015 they were they got millions
averse and they ended up with one seat
so that's 3.9 million votes and as
you're saying Michele and that it's
representative of a broken system to me
that that party ended up with one seat
in parliament that's my first point and
so many people were angry at the system
because of that now I do think that you
Kipp is finished and if I look at the
seat where I'm from whole Western has
all they came second place in 2015 and
in 2017 even I beat them they got 4% of
the verb down from a 20% in whole but to
your bigger point in your broader point
a huge amount of people myself included
feel politically homeless at the moment
I wasn't a you Kip Verta but I do feel
that there's no body in politics at the
moment that represents me there was an
election called today I wouldn't know
who to vote for which is why I stood for
election in the in the last time and my
final point is to pick you up you and
your interest said that loads of people
voted for hard brexit they didn't those
people vote it just for brexit there
wasn't this notion of hard and soft half
energy saving that's what they voted for
that's the problem I'm going she said
breaks it means breaks it you didn't
know what perks is anybody else
that's maybe means we don't know what
this means that's not a very
straightforward on the ballot paper do
you want to stay or go breakfast I say
go leaving the European Union and its
associated bodies it wasn't difficult to
understand your point that I think the
clue is in the title the UK independence
what are these people are very
independent they are very difficult to
control and when was the who was the
disgraced conservative politician in our
runs Wales as well for somebody of the
UK if you believe him even Nigel Farage
had his own battles with the enemy with
his own parties no nice even they wanted
enforced out so these are very it's like
herding cats
Boulton staying in until the
extraordinary General Assembly either
back Seymour asked since that was a
suggestion I think Henry bolte is rather
beholden to Ferrari suggestions yes yes
he famously tried to back Neil sacra
Dino they sent Union Henry Bolton's
position was untenable why has not
somebody a partner or ex-partner read
the texts I think what she said is
utterly disgusting I don't advocate in
any way shape or form but playing
devil's advocate why does what somebody
is now ex-partner thing reflect on your
ability to do a job there's a question
mark as to whether she's actually lying
there's a question mark as to whether
she's ex parte having left his wife and
two kids at Christmas for her which is
his right to do that's not my business
and unhappy divorce right that's what I
was gonna know you kind of know if
you're with someone in an intimate
relationship that they things they have
and if you haven't been able to work out
that somebody is who was that racist it
wasn't that racist then you've got some
impaired judgment going on that's what
imagine what I'd be interested to know
is what were her views before she
started dating him
I wonder if actually her joining you Kip
is what influences sort of thinking
because the way he's responded to it
it is almost in a sort of protective way
and you wonder if actually her
association with him is what fueled this
sort of thinking - I want to see how
social media channeled mrs. Merton and I
asked him so what attracted you to the
seemingly very attractive 25 racist to
which he replied well she did have four
a-levels by the time she was 50